so uh
here uh you don't have time no handko
then you have to have this angle this
diagonal angle here
and then you come around over there
there is some movement
okay boom
God
to keep his energy flowing
using that
pattern
in your body
sink into the cloth
foreign
[Music]
I do both rotations of that of that Tom
Dan field like I mentioned last time so
I'm going to do both so the one that
goes to the right then goes up goes to
the left and then down and I'm going to
do the other one to the left I'm gonna
do all in one technique okay that's what
makes keto nagada so around whoa whoa
and then I do the other side okay
God said there's a place to be okay so I
don't want to be out here I can do that
same pattern totally unrelated to him do
you understand
so you want to be in the Box
in the Box
you don't want to be in front of him
you see that difference
so same thing here don't check on
you're not in luck
so move in the Box off to the side
never in front of him
all the way around
see that difference
all the way around all the way around
off to the back
to the side
never in front of him
all the way around here
okay here's where this road
all right let's try